[Music]
movie based on a book opens with an
opening book cliche 78 minute movie
spends over 2.5 minutes on opening logos
and credits lowered Tim Hudson not a
lord
he was an English DJ who worked in Los
Angeles do you think production manager
Don duck Wall decided that with a name
like this he had no choice but to work
at Disney also hilariously this movie is
one litter off from having its music
written by George Burns many strange
legends are told of these jungles of
India narration what happened a Mobley's
parents I understand that this is being
told by the Panther and he wouldn't know
but this river doesn't seem too
treacherous if their boat got broken it
would seem logical they would still
survive and if some animal got them it
doesn't seem logical that it would just
leave the baby in the basket even if it
was full I'm sure it would still take
Mowgli home for dessert there's a
man-cub these animals all know our
language and are more eloquent than most
humans yet they don't know that we call
our young babies I would have obeyed my
first impulse and walked away with all
due respect I think your first impulse
was probably to eat or at least Maul so
basically Moses without the mom dropping
him off portion of the story oh well
this should work out nicely even if the
wolf cubs are already moving around and
will continue to get more agile while
the human will basically be useless for
the next eight or nine years at a
minimum also the movie suggests Panthers
and wolves are good buddies and not
enemies they're competitors for the same
food sources as logic would dictate
they've had no problem with a mother
thanks to the maternal instinct and as
far as speaking English or changing
diapers without opposable thumbs well I
didn't get I wasn't so sure about Rama
the father Rama doesn't immediately
think Mowgli is food I wonder which cub
will be the shunned runt now that
there's new milk competition
also does Raksha think she's going to
nurse this human baby I'd like to see
how that works but actually I take that
back ten times the rains had come and
gone so what the kind of measurement of
time is counting the rains
do you even count
Mowgli inexplicably ages at the same
rate as the other wolves does that mean
that he's going to look like an 80 year
old man at 12 years old and all the wolf
cubs love Mowgli for being different and
not remotely stealing their thunder I
knew that someday it would have to go
back to his own kind
have you ever researched feral children
it is dub and sad
spoiler alert Mowgli will not do well
with people not at all
a Shere Khan the tiger and returned to
their part of the jungle wolves and
Panthers and bears won't harm a human
but a tiger definitely will for some
reason now it is my unpleasant duty to
tell the boy's father brother come over
here please Rama who was sitting five
feet away somehow couldn't hear them
talking about sending Mowgli to the man
village
because Shir khan has returned to this
part of the jungle and he has sworn to
kill you he has he's sworn to kill a
man-cub he doesn't even yet know exists
and she had kin is not going to allow
you to grow up to become a man just
another hunter with a gun you should
also explain that he has no access to
guns because he lives with Wolves we
were notoriously bad at acquiring and
using guns Mowgli who has never even
seen another human has still developed a
sense of modesty living among the
animals who licked themselves also he's
been getting regular haircuts with bangs
up this tree you safer up there Bagheera
is going to eat his words like a sneaky
- man-cub here Disney's then propensity
to Reeves voice actors led to so much
childhood confusion like why is Winnie
the Pooh evil now go away and leave me
alone good job kid but more importantly
how heavy a sleeper is this man cups
protector cat Akira doesn't just smack
out of a cow's face right here so you
can look out for yourself can you um yes
he can't basically save both your asses
from the snake attack just now why are
you such a dick
[Music]
what are they patrolling Shere Khan is
in this part of the jungle and kah
can hypnotize so every once apparently
they're just wandering around the for us
not being effective is there only one
young male elephant
no wonder elephants are endangered my
feet are killing me
I'm putting in for a transfer to another
herd another endangered herd what's the
freaking point elephant dude
thankfully this 78 minute movie has time
for lengthy elephant military discipline
teens whew
am i right also I wonder if there's
elephant HR not they clearly need it I
don't have any of whatever he's eating
wipe off that silly grin Soulja it's
still going on you just forgot ours
I don't think hothi forgot their son as
much as their son decided to forget how
to mark if an elephant never forgets why
did they keep forgetting to give
themselves enough space to turn even
though they were walking means elephants
crash into each other like they're in a
Paul Haggis movie it's not funny
actually it is also Bagheera has zero
sense of humor Bagheera tries to disrobe
a human child back here why don't you
have a seat over here yes it's a do they
do this bear enters singing about do
beasts pandas naturally the most chill
character in this movie he's also a
Dubey bear ex machina on the timing but
still I'm not sure how many sins I can
award an actual Dubey bear so they'll
kill what the standard want why I
shouldn't have left him alone and it's
not the last time you will leave them
alone the anthers must have short-term
memory loss
oh no it's Baloo that shiftless stupid
jungle bum how does Bagheera know
everyone in the jungle the jungle is
huge surely we will run into someone he
isn't on a first-name basis with me tell
that to the bees that was a child it was
looped his entire life in the jungle
learning basically zero survival skills
[Music]
I don't need you singing the movie to
beggar 40 seconds of back and body
scratching make me super glad this movie
is wait it's barely over an hour and a
half long and it's still full of bullet
like the back scratchy nonsense if you
act like that B act
[Music]
you're working - ha movie manages to
disrespect bees who actually work super
hard and don't complain about it this
grown adult bear bee it's with the
mostly naked human child that's racist
Baloo survives this though the movie
makes them out to be villains these
monkeys look like they know how to party
this monkey looks exactly like Jim
Jarmusch
I think the monkey also just invented
air guitar the coconut makes a good
monkey mouth I'll give him that but none
of them are wearing grass skirts also he
still looks like a bear Tom and Jerry
basically everyone survives this
Mowgli seems to have man's ability to
get into trouble
Baloo got in just as much trouble as he
did I don't think the problem is
exclusive to men you can't adopt Mowgli
as your son why not
Oh Oh can I what did I have an idea for
how you could put it he's a different
species you know I'll take care of them
yes like you did when the monkeys
kidnapped him huh or like you did when
the snake almost ate it
he hates man with a vengeance you know
that because he fears man's gun and
man's fire Shere Khan may have a point I
love that kid sure after that half a
day's singing while floating in the
river blues definition of love does not
hold up to scrutiny accidental guilt
trip song you these two got real
codependent real quick
Mowgli needs to get to the man village
to find a therapist and Bloo should find
a Bera pissed I'm sorry she wouldn't
marry a panther would you do the animals
have weddings or are they just familiar
with the human construct of marriage
it's hard to tell him where the
anthropomorphizing line is in this movie
obly runs away from blue after finding
out he's going back to the human village
and somehow Baloo loses him and can't
keep up
and by their own admission in their song
their battalion is completely pointless
also movie rips off the elephants from
Dumbo a movie which was released believe
it or not 25 years prior to this one Wow
who knew just how delightful aguirre
loudly explains this to hothi
conveniently within earshot if you're a
comic character we haven't seen for this
entire film until now what preposterous
and that's racist the man-cub and I are
friends he would think the 20-second
conversation would qualify them as
friends seeing that there are no other
small elephants and he probably has no
other friends deforestation I don't
trust anyone anymore
Mowgli in 1967 perfectly sums up my 2000
this and monkeying around are basically
the only two puns in the movie which is
an incredible amount of restraint if it
were made today is a cartoon baggie or
would literally have a bag for an ear
and Baloo would be blue blatantly
reusing animation illegitimate sin
that's not how snakes walk you remember
the crows from Dumbo well now they're
vultures deal with it
i flaps what we're gonna do so now after
the Beatles turned down these roles they
couldn't find any other notable British
rock group to take their place or Nick's
the vultures Beatles idea altogether
literal group of vultures tried to sing
Mowgli back to happiness run why should
I run why should you run even the tiger
who wants to kill him is incredulous at
Mowgli's lack of survival instinct
there's no game in it why do I think a
bear would straight up own a tiger's ass
in a fight
am I wrong there that fight was really
hard yet Baloo's ass is still intact
not even a flesh wound Shere Khan needs
to check the sharpness of his teeth if
he wants to maintain a certain aura of
fear also cuz bag era right now they
couldn't have picked him up three
minutes ago when Shere Khan first showed
up a conveniently timed and police
lightning bolt is all that save Mowgli
and Baloo forget about those they
nothing but trouble that's the sound of
a bear that can't get his act together
enough to find a nice girl bear and
settle down I better look Mowgli begins
puberty even Jungle Book with a nine
year old male protagonist has to insert
some traditional male-female sexual
marital dynamics into the story they
don't cut to 20 years into the future
Mowgli is smoking a pipe and reading a
book in his living room equipped with a
suspiciously gray bear uh
to its credit nobody only has like 40
seconds of closing credits maybe that's
because they front-loaded that but still
kind of a nice breath of fresh air once
in remove
you
is something saying where Nellie you
throw them anyway private sorry touch
this door holy Doakes Texas only steers
and queers come from Texas private
cowboy and you know much look like a
steer to me so that kinda narrows it
down
you
Robin Hood and Little John walking
through the forest laughing back and
forth it what they are the necessary
[Music]
Oh
you know what would make the jungle book
better loudly fighting against the
forces of evil with intense flashing
backgrounds totally different story and
characters and done in an animation
style originating in Japan also go ahead
and remove Mowgli entirely wait country
rules already taken care of it yes
that's right because quickly rule is an
anime streaming service that offers the
largest most diverse collection of
professionally subtitled anime series
and crunchyroll premium lets you watch
them all in HD with no ads crunchyroll
premium also gets you new shows as soon
as you're an hour after they air in
Japan with subtitles the best part you
can enjoy it all free for 30 days when
you go to crunchyroll.com slash
cinemasins yes that's a month of
unlimited professionally subtitled anime
manga and drama titles that you can
enjoy on all your devices all you have
to do is click the link in the
description or head to crunchyroll.com
slash cinemasins to get started
[Music]